خرجوا الى الحياه مجددا بعدما عاشوا اهوال
الزلزال اطفال سوريون في الخيام افتقد
بعضهم الخدمات الطبيه الاساسيه في مخيمات
مدينه اصلاحيه بولايه غاز عنتاب موظفوه
مركز صحه المهاجرين المسؤول عن اللاجئين
ومتطوعون اتراك يجوبون الخيام بحثا عن
اطفال لم يتلقوا اللقاح بسبب الزلزال يحيى
متطوع تركي جاء من دوسجه شمالي تركيا
للمساعده في هذه المبادره
سالك نكمل لقاحات ناقصه للاطفال حديثي
الولاده ولمن هم بعمر سته اشهر وتسعه اشهر
و12 شهرا نتفقد الخيام ونقدم خدماتنا لهم
كثير من العائلات السوريه لم تستطع تامين
اللقاحات لاطفالهم بسبب دمار لحق بمراكز
طبيه تعنى بهم
من زلزال وجينا لهون على المخيم باركنا
وبنتي هان ما كان فيه ما جبنا لوحات ما في
مراكز
صحه المهاجرين الحمد لله يعطيها العافيه
لكن الظروف القاسيه لذويهم تحتاج المزيد
من الرعايه والاهتمام خصوصا في ظل غياب
الكثير من الخدمات عنهم زيدان زنجلو
العربيه من مدينه اصلاحيه غازي عنتاب